just to the west of the new city of
Flagstaff Arizona beneath the starry sky
stands of ponderosa pines marching off
into the distance
[Music]
they're enshrined in a domed Observatory
atop the peak of a modest Mesa
despite the lateness of the hour a
solitary figure works surrounded by some
of the finest astronomical equipment of
his age watched over by the silent trees
the year is 1909 is Percival Lowell and
he is studying Mars
a wealthy American businessman Lowell
established this Observatory in order to
pursue his singular all-consuming
passion the study of the red planet the
observatory and the 24 inch telescope it
houses is the first in the world to be
sighted at altitude on top of Mars Hill
as it will come to be known Lowell's
telescope is more than 2,000 meters
above sea level enjoying the benefits of
an extraordinarily clear view of the
heavens with less atmosphere to distort
the light on its way to Earth's surface
the new Observatory reveals stars and
planets with remarkable clarity so
Lowell sits in the observing chair
colossal telescope - one I notebook in
his lap
and in this age long before the first
accurate photographs of the planets Oh
what riches can he see great waterways
singular and doubled up criss crossing
the Martian landscape joined by Oasis
great pools of water like reservoirs and
he sees vegetation along the canals
vegetation that waxes and wanes with the
passing of the seasons
[Music]
what could be the explanation for this
complex terrain surely this isn't
something that could arise from natural
forces alone
[Music]
very much a man of his time living in an
age of empire industry and railways
Lowell concludes that the only rational
explanation for DC's is intelligent
Minds executing vast civil engineering
projects these Martians must be highly
advanced T reasons but desperate their
planet is drying out losing its water so
they have no choice but to travel it
from the polar ice caps to their towns
and farmlands at lower latitudes what
terrible misfortune that Mars was dying
the Martians going to such great lengths
to survive
[Music]
lols work was evocative sparking the
public's imagination as well as the
likes of HG Wells of War of the Worlds
Fame
but it also attracted criticism no other
scientists could see what Lowell was
seeing they didn't see his canals always
away sees all the summer bloom perhaps
it was because the new observatory
revealed closely held secrets no others
could see or perhaps Percival Lowell was
carried away with wishful thinking at
the time it was impossible to know for
sure and the imaginative public would
have to wait nearly 70 years to know if
the Martians and their canals really did
exist
[Music]
the answer finally came in the 1960s
with the first unmanned missions to Mars
robotic probes dispatched by NASA known
as the Mariner missions
[Music]
orbiting the Red Planet these first
travelers to another world captured the
first close-up images of the surface
[Music]
those images grainy and indistinct
showed a rugged cratered surface there
was no trace of water but no trace of
Lowell's canals either
with subsequent orbiting missions and
eventually Landers and Rovers to Mars
history has gradually given up its
secrets there never was an ancient
civilization of Martians here and it's
been a very very long time since there
was any water yet at some point in the
near unfathomable depths of time water
there was
[Music]
at the same time as mariner offered up
new perspectives on Mars another space
mission provided brand new perspectives
on our world
[Music]
in December 1972 as Apollo 17 made its
way to the moon
for the final lunar landing of the space
race one of the astronauts on board
turned his camera to the earth
[Music]
home to every human who has ever lived
every story that was ever told the image
she captured known as the Blue Marble
has since become an icon of unity and of
course fragility when seen from space
our world is spectacularly blue adorned
with delicate wisps and whirls of cloud
graceful ice caps and frosted floes
compared to dry dusty red Mars our
planet couldn't be more different a lush
ocean world brimming with water in all
its guises but how did the two worlds
end up so different what became of the
oceans of Mars and where did our water
come from
[Applause]
[Music]
whirling through space at about 150
million kilometers away from our Sun the
earth is the only planet in our solar
system with abundant water more than 70%
of its surface is covered with ocean and
places plunging 10 kilometers deep
there's enough water in our oceans to
fill 550 trillion Olympic swimming pools
but there's also water in rivers and in
lakes the trace delicate sinuous
patterns will across the land surface
underground aquifers contain fresh
groundwater that can penetrate the rock
up to 2 kilometers down not to mention
the many millions of cubic kilometers
locked away in ice sheets glacis and
Berg's and water is in the atmosphere
too as a gas it's a small but
significant part of the blanket coating
our sphere creating humidity the sticky
closeness of a hot tropical evening at
higher altitudes it exists as a liquid
tiny droplets suspended by rising air
currents clouds and higher still the
clouds freeze dice ready to begin their
descent back to the surface our world is
ruled by water
it's evolution guided by it our water is
the lubricant that keeps plate tectonics
going keeps the rocks recycling our
water is the reason life has flourished
here for billions of years
our water is what defines our earth
but the story of how water got here in
the first place is far from
straightforward it's a mystery
concealed by the depths of time only now
in the 21st century being revealed by
cutting-edge new research when the earth
formed 4.5 four billion years ago it did
so in a region of space lacking the
ingredients to forge life-giving water
the newborn son was powerful enough to
strip the inner parts of the
protoplanetary disk clean of hydrogen
the lightweight element that makes up
two-thirds of a water molecule without
hydrogen there could be no water so all
of the planets of the inner solar system
were born dry barren rocks
perhaps some water could have escaped
the young son's relentless gale if it
hitched a ride bound chemically to
particles of dust when the dust began to
cling together into swelling planetary
embryos the water was trapped within
still bound to the rocks inside these
planets only after millions of years of
grinding plate tectonics and overturning
bringing these inner rocks to the
planet's surface could that water be
released
but could a trillion trillion liters of
water really be locked away inside a
planet during its formation maybe some
of the Earth's water dates to its
earliest days but scientists don't think
this is the whole story
instead they look to altogether more
alien sources
[Music]
for while the inner solar system was
swept clean of water the outer reaches
were wash with it their further away
from the Sun temperatures were cool
enough for hydrogen to combine with
oxygen and condense then freeze into icy
crystals each ice crystal is tiny but
beyond the so called snow line of our
solar system space is awash with frozen
water locked up inside asteroids comets
even inside the Giants Neptune and
Uranus but these water rich bodies are
enormously distant they're more than
four times the distance between our
world and the Sun a vast Gulf of space
opening up between the young dry earth
and this remote interplanetary reservoir
it would take a planetary turmoil for
their paths to cross over the distance
luckily for the earth planetary turmoil
is exactly what the early solar system
looks like giant gas worlds like Jupiter
and Saturn form and jostle for a stable
orbit among unruly proto planets gravity
pulls and pushes planets into new orbits
flinging smaller objects across the
solar system as Jupiter moves first
towards and then away from the Sun it
passes through icy bodies at the snow
line throwing them into a tumult some
are ejected from the solar system
entirely launched on million year
journeys to parts unknown
others are flung inwards towards the
inner reaches of the solar system
towards the Earth
many myths of course but enough were
drawn in by the Earth's gravity pulled
onto an inescapable collision course
when they hit the incredible heat and
force of the impacts obliterate four
smaller bodies rock is smashed to dust
and ice flashes into vapor
the water vapor eventually cooling to
liquid water belongs to earth now each
impact may only deliver a little water
to the earth but together over the span
of millions of years these icy asteroids
and comets leave oceans in their wake if
even a small fraction of them struck our
planet these icy bodies could easily be
the source of our endless oceans
for a long time comets had been seen as
the most likely cosmic couriers bringing
water to our world after all
compared to rocky asteroids comets are
made almost entirely of ice it would
take far fewer collisions for them to
cover earth with water
[Music]
yet in the last few years
spacecraft have visited both comets and
asteroids
providing new data that's fundamentally
changed our view concluding that it was
in fact rocky asteroids that delivered
most of the water to earth and the inner
solar system the molecular fingerprint
of ice from comets is completely
irreconcilable different to that of
Earth's water in this forensic study the
prime suspect left no evidence at the
scene but the molecular fingerprint of
asteroid ice is a match for Earth's
water all clues point to asteroids
jostle by Jupiter in the early days of
the solar system as the source of our
seas
but space probes haven't solved the
mystery of when this happened
Jupiter's mighty lurch back and forth
through the solar system would have
happened within the first 100 million
years but it could have stirred up the
asteroids so badly that they lingered in
the inner solar system for many more
millions of years no rocks on earth
survived from these earliest of days
most likely the asteroid bombardment
took place after the catastrophic
collision between Earth and Theia since
that cataclysmic event would have been
powerful enough to strip our planet of
any atmosphere including water but
there's also good evidence of a
bombardment happening after the moon's
formation one need only to look up at
the moon's face today to see the clues
staring back at us many of the craters
of our eternal companion were formed
during a relatively thin sliver of its
early history between around 4.1 and 3.8
billion years ago
scientists call this cataclysmic era the
late heavy bombardment and as well as
cratering the moon similar impacts on
the earth may have delivered its water
to one final clue points to our water
being extraterrestrial in origin as well
as having a surface that's uniquely
water rich the crust also contains a
remarkable quantity of gold elements
like gold don't usually stick around
with rock inside planets rather they go
where the iron goes torn by the pull of
gravity
usually during the formation of a world
gold would be stripped from the crust
and dragged down by gravity into the
iron core but our crust is gilded one of
the only ways this could have happened
is if the gold was delivered after the
core had already formed delivered by
asteroids that left a thin veneer of
precious metals and precious water on
the surface
while the origins of Earth's water may
still be uncertain its fate is easier to
predict
[Music]
because our home planet formed at a
distance from the Sun that's not too hot
and not too cold astronomers call it the
Goldilocks zone for this very reason
within the Goldilocks zone it's just
right for water to exist as a liquid
not only that but with small
fluctuations and conditions a little
thicker atmosphere a slight tilt away
from the Sun that liquid water can
easily switch between its other phases
within just 100 degrees Celsius water
can freeze solid into ice or evaporate
away into tenuous vapor 100 degrees
might seem a lot to us but between the
scorching heat of stars and the frigid
depths of space it's tremendous luck
that puts earth just in the place where
conditions are right for all three to
exist and it's precisely this
coexistence of the three phases of water
that powers our world after the
bombardment that delivered the water
physical reactions took over water vapor
suspended in the atmosphere eventually
cools and condenses forming tiny cloud
droplets the battered earth is now
swaddled in cloud
[Music]
within these clouds the droplets merge
some freeze and eventually they fall
rain and snow fall for the first time on
to Earth's rocky surface hissing and
spitting as they land on the still
cooling crust this first rain storm may
have lasted for thousands of years
liquid water on the surface flows
downhill from the summit's of mountains
and volcanoes to the crumpled and
shattered valleys below on its way
gradually wears away the rock beneath
the first river channels begin to form
in the depressions water collects first
as puddles then ponds and as the valleys
are filled by relentless river flow
Lakes
begin to fall
before spilling over onto one another as
water levels rise
the first seas and oceans are born slow
chemical reactions begin between the new
alien water and the rocks and atmosphere
it encounters water dissolves some
minerals creates new compounds gradually
the compositions transform rainwater
falling through a carbon dioxide rich
atmosphere becomes acidic acid rain eats
away at rock the oceans become salty
[Music]
near the poles where the Sun is low and
the winter nights are long temperatures
drop below zero and water freezes solid
snow falls instead of rain and over
thousands of years individual flakes
accumulate into mite Iglesias perched at
the peaks of mountains the glaciers edge
downhill excruciating ly slowly grinding
rock into dust as they pass at their
feet the ice melts back into the growing
global ocean
but closer to the tropics temperatures
are much warmer and the Sun high in the
sky heats the new ocean surface the
water evaporates filling the atmosphere
again with invisible vapor that rises
cools and condenses into clouds the
cycle begins anew
from the first water to today the
molecules delivered to the earth all
those billions of years ago have stuck
around passing through land sea and air
in a global water cycle that powers our
weather and climate shaping the
landscape with intractable force
through the water cycle temperature
ultimately controls climate and weather
yet it's hard to know what the climate
of the early Earth really was over it's
four billion year history the planet has
found itself gripped by ice coating
almost the entire surface it has also
been through warm phases where no ice at
all lingered at the poles we only know
about these periods from the rock record
left behind and there are no rocks from
the Earth's earliest days
[Music]
astronomers think that the Sun burned
dimmer and cooler when it was first born
so the earth too would have been cooler
without its warming glow to evaporate
the oceans the water cycle slows less
rain fewer rivers flowing and gradually
lakes and oceans freeze the early
climate could have been a cold frozen
desert earth frigid snowball until the
Sun matured soaring it out
but that was probably not the case after
the moon-forming collision during the
Hadean volcanoes spewed gases into the
skies which accumulated thickening into
the first atmosphere and the composition
of that atmosphere was very different to
today it was rich in carbon dioxide and
methane that together have a remarkable
warming effect heat from the Sun can
pass in through the atmosphere but these
gases act like a blanket to stop it
escaping again so even though the early
Sun was weaker Earth's atmosphere was
probably a much more powerful insulator
with the warmth locked in it could have
powered a very active water cycle
leading to a steamy tropical climate
with intense stormy weather the weather
of the Hadean may just have been as
violent as the Earth's own convulsions
and yet however violent the storms
however gripping the ice ages Earth's
water are stuck around cycling between
atmosphere oceans and ice caps for
almost 4 billion years
some of it might be locked into rocks
and subducting into the earth during
plate tectonics but it eventually
emerges when volcanoes erupt again the
relentless solar wind sweeps past the
planet threatening to blow away the
atmosphere and any water vapor it
contains but the Earth's magnetic field
generated in the swirling iron core is a
shield against this erosive Gale
deflecting it and keeping the atmosphere
and oceans intact Earth has kept its
water all this time but Mars was not so
lucky the same asteroid bombardment that
delivered water to earth likely did the
same to Mars just on the edge of the
Goldilocks habitable zone though his
evidence turned out to be little more
than a mirage Percival Lowell was right
to conclude that Mars had suffered a
water crisis the Red Planet probably did
have an ocean atmosphere and weather
just like the earth though he couldn't
have possibly fathomed how long ago this
had been
[Music]
today the two planets couldn't be any
more different
while Earth sweats under a humid blanket
Mars is a silent barren desert the
explanation for this lies beyond the
reach of any telescope deep at the
center of these rocky worlds
it turns out we owe our oceans not only
to the luck of our orbit but also to the
size of the planet itself because while
the earth was large enough hot enough to
maintain its protective magnetic field
Mars was not so lucky it's little more
than half the size of Earth and while it
may have started out with a swirling
core and magnetic shield
its smaller size meant it cooled much
more quickly the core gradually froze
grinding to a halt and the magnetic
field all but disappeared without its
protection the solar wind battered the
Martian atmosphere and surface stripping
away the gas and the liquid water until
all that was left was ice at the poles
that's the Mars we see today a planet
once gifted then robbed of its water
long before any Martian civilization had
the chance to evolve
[Music]
looking back to earth considering how
much our planet has been shaped by luck
and chance events the ocean world we
call home is even more wondrous
[Music]
next time we investigate how the immense
volcanic forces of plate tectonics help
shape our world and finally we
investigate our first life began to form
you've been watching the entire history
of the earth don't forget to Like and
subscribe let us know what you think in
the comments I will see you next time
[Music]